[Music]
before we get started though I wanted to
mention something briefly this is
obviously the part of the show where I
come out and we talk about what's going
on in the news and as everybody knows
the news these last few days has been
absolutely horrific and of course
everyone who works at this show everyone
here in the audience's thoughts and
prayers are with the families affected
by Friday's insanely mindless tragedy
and as you can imagine I came into work
today and the last thing I wanted to do
was comb through the newspaper and try
and find something funny so if you don't
mind tonight I thought what we might do
is just skip the news part of the show
and instead just do silly and pointless
comedy I thought that might be
[Applause]
because when you think about it when you
think about it that's all I'm really
good at that might be my the reason I've
been put on earth yeah yeah instead do
stuff that has completely no point no
bearing on anything it entertains you
you laugh and then 20 minutes later you
think that was stupid I thought this is
what I would do tonight which is a
little different I thought maybe to you
know get the show started
instead of doing some jokes I just bring
out our most popular Christmas character
of all time minty the candy cane who
briefly fell on the ground
[Applause]
here I've been shooting everyone
[Music]
it seemed like a great idea okay and
then of course there's this problem that
comes up that I didn't realize minty was
played by one of our writers Brian
McCann there's Brian McCann as minty the
candy cane who briefly fell on the
ground and recently Brian left our show
to move on to bigger and better things
after working with us for many many
years and now he lives over 3,000 miles
away and yeah I know and I and I thought
well maybe we get someone else to play
Mindy but if we did that it wouldn't be
right
I think people would notice and it would
feel wrong yeah and so we're gonna do
some really silly stuff I promise you
that we're going to entertain you but
I'm afraid it's not going to be minty
yeah I'm sorry
there's nothing I can do my hands are
tied
[Applause]
it can't be what
is it really humidity just play the damn
song you can't hear the
[Applause]
he fell on the ground
people on the ground the ball it's not
easy to explain why am I dressed as a
candy candy but Emma fine just have a
good time signal on two fifties rhyme
keep it on the ground now he's covered
in entire
[Music]
[Applause]